a woman like Amber Heard who has dated
Elon Musk and Johnny Depp does not want
to settle for less she doesn't want to
but we should probably will okay you
know and why are you talking point stop
talking listen okay
she might have to because of her
reputation okay she doesn't want to okay
okay fine who the hell is Gisele going
to date yeah but you can't compare
yourself why are you talking very Amber
Heard they're two different situations
gentlemen
like they're two different women
gentlemen that's two different
situations listen I love women I love
being around women just so listen you
could tell them what to do all day long
not just listen
nah let me explain something
I'm trying to explain something